>> WHITE HOUSE STAFFERS NOT
HAPPY THAT SOME OF THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA ARE NOT GIVING
ENOUGH CREDIT FOR THEIR HISTORIC
WHEN SPARED ON COMPLETING A
TWITTER WITH THIS: >> HISTORIC
LOW FOR UNEMPLOYMENT CLAIMS,
HISTORIC INTERNATIONAL EFFORTS
TO PROVIDE RELIEF ON PUTIN'S
PRICE HIKE, CAN'T FIND COVERAGE
THAT OF ANY OF IT.
CRITICS POINT TO BIDEN'S CURRENT
CRISES HAS THE REAL STORY AND
INFLATION IS NOT AT HISTORIC 40
ARE HIGH.
AMERICANS FACED THE HIGHEST
ANNUAL INCREASE IN FOOD COSTS
SINCE 2008 AND THE PRESIDENT'S
CRISIS AT THE SOUTHERN BORDER IS
ALSO HISTORIC AS BHS PROJECTS
18,000 ILLEGALS CROSSING IN PER
DAY.
ON THE UNPRESIDENTIAL PROBLEMS
FOR HIS SON, HUNTER BIDEN, SEEMS
TO BE PICKING UP STEAM.
HE HAS QUITE A BIT ON HIS PLATE.
KATIE, DO YOU FEEL LIKE THE
COVERAGE -- I KNOW THE ANSWER TO
THIS BEFORE I ASK IT, DO YOU
THINK THE COVERAGE IS UNFAIR?
>> I THINK IF YOU ARE A
DEMOCRATIC ADMINISTRATION OF THE
WHITE HOUSE COMPLAINING ABOUT
COVERAGE IN THE D.C. PRESS,
WHETHER IT'S POLITICO OR ANY
OTHER OUTLET, THEN YOU KNOW YOUR
POLICIES ARE NOT BEING -- ARE
NOT GOING WELL IN THE STATE OF
THE COUNTRY HAS A PROBLEM.
HAVING GOOD PRESS IN POLITICO IS
NOT GOING TO CHANGE THE REALITY
FOR THE MAJORITY OF AMERICANS IN
THIS COUNTRY.
THE LOWER MIDDLE CLASSES WERE
DEALING WITH INFLATION, THEY ARE
DEALING WITH THE EMPLOYMENT
PICTURE.
THE SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS, THE
PEOPLE ON THE BORDER ARE LEAVING
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND
DROUGHTS AS A RESULT OF THE OPEN
BORDER POLICIES.
THAT'S JUST AN INDICATION THE
ADMINISTRATION IS HAVING A
REALLY TOUGH TIME BREAKING
THROUGH WITH THEIR
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AS A RESULT OF
ALL OF THE OTHER THINGS THAT ARE
GOING WRONG FOR THEM.
>> YOU KNOW, JESSICA, THIS MADE
ME THINK OF PRESIDENT OBAMA WHEN
HE WAS AT THE CEREMONY THE OTHER
DAY LIKE WHAT SHOULD I DO ABOUT
THE MIDTERMS AND HE SAID JUST
TELL THE STORY, TELL THE STORY
OF EVERYTHING THAT IS GOOD,
RIGHT?
BUT I THINK MORE AND MORE,
ESPECIALLY IN THE WORLD WE'RE
LIVING IN ORONO, PEOPLE PEOPLE
KNOW THE STORY.
THEY GET BOMBARDED WITH MEDIA
WHETHER IT'S ON THE RIGHT OR THE
LEFT, BUT THEY KNOW THE REALITY
OF WHAT THEY ARE FEELING IN
THEIR LIVES.
AND I DON'T KNOW THAT IT
MATTERS, BECAUSE KATIE'S POINT,
WHETHER OR NOT POLITICO IT'S
NICE ENOUGH TO THEM.
>> DOESN'T.
THE AVERAGE AMERICAN GOING OUT
TO VOTE IS NOT READING POLITICO.
THE STORY OF HOW YOUR LIFE IS
GOING IS TOLD IN THE PLACES WE
GO EVERY DAY.
THE GROCERY STORE, THE GAS PUMP,
WHEN YOU TALK TO YOUR FAMILY OR
FRIENDS CAN BE RELATIVES ON THE
PHONE.
OBVIOUSLY THAT STORY IN THIS
PARTICULAR MOMENT IS NOT A
FANTASTIC ONE FOR THE DEMOCRATS.
I WILL SAY THOUGH THAT I DO
THINK THAT PARTISANSHIP IS
REALLY IMPORTANT.
I HEARD A LOT OF PEOPLE, A LOT
OF CONSERVATIVES COMPLAINING
ABOUT EVEN THE COVERAGE THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS SAYING AND
GETTING IN SOME CONSERVATIVE
OUTLETS.
THING THEY ARE NOT PRO-TRUMP
ENOUGH.
THESE PEOPLE ARE RHINOS, PEOPLE
I'VE KNOWN MY ENTIRE ADULT LIFE
TO BE IN CRUDE CRITICAL PEOPLE.
THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE STILL
GOING TO LINE UP AND THE BOX FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP ANY TIME HE'S ON
THE BALLOT.
AS AN EXAMPLE ON THE DEMOCRATIC
SIDE LIBERALS HATE CHUCK TODD
NOW.
THEY THINK CHUCK CODD IS A
CONSERVATIVE, ESSENTIALLY.
THIS IS WHAT I'M SAYING, THIS IS
WHAT GOES ON IN THESE BUBBLES
BECAUSE HE DOES --
SENATOR RON JOHNSON ON ALL THE
TIME, REPEATED THE BIG LIE ABOUT
THE ELECTION.
HE DOESN'T PUSH BACK HARD ENOUGH
SO EVERYONE LIVES IN THESE
LITTLE BUBBLES, ESPECIALLY WHEN
YOU ARE A MEET THE PRESS KIND OF
WATER.
THEY'RE COMPLAINING ABOUT
WHATEVER IS HAPPENING TO THEIR
PARTY.
>> THIS PAST WEEK AND KNOW ABOUT
THESE THINGS WE JUST POINTED OUT
COMPETITORS AS FACTS OF WHAT IS
GOING ON, JESSE.
SPRIG OF THE WHITE HOUSE HAS
SOME NERVE WHINING ABOUT PRESS
CONFERENCE COVERAGE FOR THE
PRESCOTT HYMN OF THE WHITE HOUSE
ONLY COVERED UP THE LAPTOP.
THAT WOULD BE LIKE IF GREG GAVE
ME A YACHT AND I COMPLAINED THAT
IT WAS NOT THE COLOR I WANTED TO
GREG WHAT TO SAY GIVE ME THE
YACHT BACK.
THAT'S WHAT THE MEDIA CAN DO.
THEY CREATED THE BIDEN
PRESIDENCY AND THEY CAN DESTROY
IT LIKE THIS.
IF THEY START REPORTING ON
WHAT'S REALLY IN THAT LAPTOP
THIS PRESIDENCY IS OVER.
AND TO SAY THEY DON'T DO THIS,
THEY DON'T DO THAT -- IS NOT
JUST A LAP DOG, THEY DON'T COVER
CRIME.
THEY DON'T COVER THE BORDER.
THEY DON'T COVER HIS MENTAL
UNFITNESS.
WE ARE ACTING LIKE THIS
PRESIDENCY IS HITTING A ROUGH
PATCH -- IT'S A DISASTER.
THE PRESS CORPS IS WONDERING
JUST WHEN THE EASTER EGG ROLL IS
REALLY GOING TO GO DOWN PIER
THEY REALLY DON'T READ THIS GUY
THE WAY THAT THEY SHED.
>> BUT EVERY PRESIDENCY, CRAIG
SAYS YOU'RE NOT COVERING OUR
GOOD STORY ENOUGH.
>> THERE ALWAYS COMPLAINING.
BUT THIS FELLOW OVER HERE MADE A
VERY GOOD POINT.
I PROVED TO JESSICA THAT WE ARE
NOT AS PARTISAN AS WE LOOK I'M
GOING TO COMPLEMENT THE
WHITE HOUSE ON THE CONFIRMATION
OF THE SUPREME COURT JUSTICE.
THEY ALL LOOKED WELL-GROOMED.
>> SO THE WHITE HOUSE SHOULD BE
UPSET COME OF THE OLD LINE ABOUT
LOYALTIES HE DID NOT SHOOT
INSIDE THE TENT, RIGHT?
WE KIND OF NOTE -- STUDIES SHOW
THE MEDIA, THE DEMOCRATS SHARE
THE SAME TENT.
IT'S EQUIVALENT WENT CHUCK TODD
CRITICIZES THE WHITE HOUSE, IT'S
THE EQUIVALENT OF WILL SMITH
GETTING UPSET BECAUSE HIS WIFE
IS TALKING SMACK ABOUT THEIR
MARRIAGE.
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE HEARING RIGHT
NOW.
DO NOT SUPPOSED TO DO THAT.
BUT THE OTHER QUESTION -- WHEN
YOU SAID IT IS A DISASTER, THE
ADMINISTRATION RIGHT NOW IT'S IN
BAD SHAPE.
YOU HAVE THE MIDTERMS
APPROACHING.
THE PULLING ESPECIALLY IN CRIME
IN THE ECONOMY JUST LOOKS REALLY
GRIM.
BUT WHY AREN'T THE DEMOCRATS
PANICKING?
I FEEL LIKE THERE IS SOMETHING
UP THEIR SLEEVE.
LIKE THEY ALWAYS HAVE.
I MEAN FACE IT, WHAT IS THE NEXT
BIG HOST?
YOU HAD COLLISION, YOU HAD THE
PEE TAPE, YOU HAD THE LAPTOP,
YOU'RE GOING TO NEED SOMETHING
SUPER BIG TO SHAKE UP THIS BOX.
YOU KNOW IT'S COMING.
IT'S GOING TO HAVE EVERYBODY
SCRAMBLING, THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN
YOU FIND OUT IS NOT GOING TO BE
REAL BUT IT MIGHT BE TOO LATE.
DON'T YOU THINK THAT'S
HAPPENING?
>> NOW I'M REALLY NERVOUS.
IT'S GOING TO BE SOMETHING
REALLY BIG.
>> THERE IS NOTHING BIGGER THAN
THE PEE TAPE.
>> I HAVE IT ON VHS.
>> ALL THAT IS WHERE IT IS?
PIGGYBACKING SOME OF THE STUFF
ON THAT LAPTOP I'M LIKE I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THAT IS NOT SAFE FOR
WORK AT ALL.
ALREADY, CNN'S BRAIN CELLS ARE